اعلنت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
يونيوسف ان سبعه ملايين طفل في سوريا
وتركيا معرضون للخطر واوضحت ان حوالي
مليونين و500 الف طفل باتوا في خطر عقب
الزلزال في سوريا وكذلك الامر بالنسبه
لاكثر من اربعه ملايين الف في تركيا
تحديدا يونيسف اوضحت ايضا ان عائلات هؤلاء
الاطفال تواجه ظروفا صعبه ناجمه عن
الكارثه سيما وانهم دون مساكن ايوائيه
معرضون لمخاطر الاصابه بالكوليرا وامراض
اخرى كما اكدت المنظمه مواصله تقييم الوضع
وتحديد المخاطر المحتمله في كل من سوريا
وتركيا وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو
اهلا بك سيد فراس يعني
اليونيسف تتخوف من
تفشي للاوبئه في سوريا ماذا عن الوضع في
تركيا وما المعلومات المتوفره هل رصدتم اي
مؤشرات
الخيم الاماكن التي يتجمع فيها الاطفال
دون اي مقومات للحياه
وحتى الان يعني لم يتم الاعلان عن اي يعني
مرض او اي افه او اي شيء من هذا الامور
الصحيه لكن وزير الصحه كان تكلم قبل فتره
قريبه جدا
ان وزاره الصحه تاخذ بين اعتبار المخاوف
الصحيه من انتشار او بيئه في مناطق التي
المناطق المدن العشر التي ضربها الزلزال
لذلك اظن ان
كما قال ان هناك ايضا يعني لنقل الاستنفار
طبيا في الداخل التركي حتى من الولايات
الاخرى تم استجلام كثير من الممرضين
والاطباء في في هذا الامر لكن حتى الان لم
يتم الاعلان عن اي امر لك ايضا لم يتم
الاعلان عن هل تم اعطاء يعني جرعات اضافيه
دوائيه او من هذا القبيل لم يذكر ذلك لان
بشكل عام ربما النظام الصحي في تركيا
يعتمد على الاطفال منذ لديهم نظام
المتابعه
للقاحات وما شابه ذلك لكن الان حتى الان
اظن يعني الامور يتكلمون على ان لم يحصل
شيء لكن التخوفات موجوده لماذا لان لم يتم
نقل حتى الان كل الذين تضرروا من الزلزال
الى اماكن لنقل صحيه على الاقل للخياميه
ليست صحيحه حتى مراكز الايواء ليست صحيه
بسبب الاقتصاد الذي موجوده فيه لكن اظن
هذا سيحل مع البلديه
الحكومه في هذا الامر الى ذلك الوقت
سننتظر التقارير الطبيه من وزاره الصحه
التركيه